greetings podcastville welcome to the
church of what's happening now it's
brought to you by
zip recruiter are you hiring do you know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates no you don't do me a favor
go to zip recruiter for free that's
right free just go to ziprecruiter.com
church that's ziprecruiter.com
church number two
on it.com the best supplements period
from shroom tech sport alpha brain hem
force protein you can't [ __ ] go wrong
go to honor dot com slash church boom
and get ten percent off delivered right
to your [ __ ] door let's get
this party started
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
it's the church of what's happening now
[ __ ]
monday october august 7th here we go
like a black cat dude are you [ __ ]
kidding me
it's gonna be that type of monday
[ __ ] it's not a bad day is it
it's gonna be when they get this podcast
mr saturday night it's the church of
what's happening now
my jewish goomba lee syed
and the man of steel mr ron white
here's what i'm talking about on monday
[ __ ] morning
good afternoon good evening mr white how
are you sir
i feel like a hundred pesos oh my god
that's the [ __ ] weed that killed
carrie fish i'm telling you that's al
patron
that's what you gotta smoke for the
series uh the netflix premiere of narcos
that's the weeds you gotta smoke right
there what's going on my man
you know i just came by here and you
just got me so [ __ ] up in about 30
minutes and i'm just i'm going to be
like well this would be great people
just to see just how brain dead i can
possibly [ __ ] become thank you joey
oh this tequila is tremendous i haven't
drank in the wild but this is tremendous
telling they're ridiculous
one more the key was probably the most
fun like i think that's what i wanted
you know it's a it's a
right down the block here studio city
this is the [ __ ] jerry lewis gives the
kids before he shoots him
he gives him one of these listen you're
not good you're not selling no more
tickets
you got to go get hit by another car or
something's gonna happen
all right
oh my god ron white where the [ __ ] do we
start
you tell me man this is you you're you
know what i uh
i came i came down here today to do this
because i'm such a big fan and i i don't
i don't know i mean i guess uh
one of the things that's that
you know when i started when i moved
back we moved to l.a
and uh and i think as you know i want to
be a part of the comedy community you
know i want to be a part of it i don't
want to hang out on the edges and walk
in i want to be a dead [ __ ] in the
middle of it
you know just having a good time doing
what i do it's the only thing i do so i
love being you know i like being a part
of it i don't care if somebody's a an
open mind or they make 10 times more
money than i do like somebody does
i'm just [ __ ] with you now where'd
you live before full-time
i had a place up in uh montecito uh
california where i just sat on the deck
and looked at the ocean and
drank and uh did nothing and now i still
drink but i go in and do sets every you
know when i'm home you know i always go
out and do sets so
that's the [ __ ] most fun i can have
it makes me relaxed if i don't if i
don't go out and do sets every night i'm
pinned up i feel like i'm here for no
reason
and uh and it just you know it makes me
[ __ ] smile just to go out and let
people love me you know you you i mean
oh my god they let them love me there's
no wrong there's nothing wrong with that
i [ __ ] love my [ __ ] love on me man
the ninth time because i always call up
for the holidays
there's something about the store on the
holidays that makes my dick hard whether
it's thanksgiving night
christmas yeah right right and this year
i called in fighting christmas eve or
christmas night i never look at the
lineup i just want to go down there and
get surprised i get out of my car and
there you are dressed to the nines
and i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
down here saying you are doing the set
and i'm like god damn
i called rogan the next one i'm like
rogan where the [ __ ] were you last night
with my family we were down at the store
having a [ __ ] blessing
toasted
oh my god and that's what
i guess that's what being a comic is i
mean you never end it never ends
well you know this
it's the camaraderie of people that are
it's such a number one is stamp comedy
is a tiny tiny subculture
i mean there's just not very they're way
more [ __ ]
uh brain surgeons than there are
people that make
a living doing stand-up comedy you know
it's a small subculture
and uh i find for the most part not
always but for the most part they're
people i can [ __ ] hang with
you know because we you know we know the
same people we've had the same
experiences you know most of us that
have you know road our ass off until it
was eroded and
and uh you know so it's just
especially the store because you can sit
back there's a
there's a there's a place i don't know
nobody knows this or maybe you do
but uh at the store there's a place for
comedians to smoke weed and be who they
are and they've always embraced the
insanity of stand-up comedians they've
always known the best ones were crazy as
[ __ ] and so they're like let's make a
craziest [ __ ] spot and let the crazy
[ __ ] people have a place to be while
they're doing stand up and that's why
you know looking prior they built a
[ __ ] glass piano for him to do blow
off of like if you're going to be crazy
please
be crazy here and tell jokes on our
[ __ ] stage and that's
why carlin and kennison and and you know
all the
all the devils
you know they all came over here you
know the the angels came up over at the
improv so i i usually gravitate towards
and i love working both clubs and uh
and luckily not everybody can but uh but
uh
you know it's a it's a it's a blast but
if you go to the improv and go hey where
can i smoke some weed they're like well
you have to actually stand on melrose
avenue
in traffic to do it that's that's where
that's what we got worked out for you
i'm like really
yeah yeah they hear you you get to hear
the story you park your car right next
to the building and
you know walk on in it's great it's it's
fun
now where was the first time you got up
on stage where the [ __ ] was it what do
you claim who claims you
uh well the there was a called the funny
bone comedy club in arlington texas and
uh
this guy that i where was a window
salesman
and uh
this guy that i worked with went to the
first open mic night that they had there
after the club first opened and uh
he came to the office the next day and
he goes ron
you're funnier than these guys you
should go do this
and i was like really you think so
yeah i know so i
watched everybody you're you're better
than they are you go go do this so
as i went down there at audition for one
person which is so humiliating there's
one person there with their arms crossed
and i've got four minutes of [ __ ] you
know pure [ __ ] unadulterated crap
and uh one thing gotta laugh
they decided to let me on and
and uh
then i remember the guy
i forget his name but uh he's a black
comic and uh
ryan's name was ron something and uh
he remember he goes please enjoy the
comedy stylings of ron white and i'm
walking towards the stage and i'm like
stylings stuff
stylings and i'm just nervous as [ __ ]
and i didn't expect him to say stylings
and then
i didn't
but but i did okay in the for my four
minutes
and but the next week and then nobody
was there i didn't tell anybody i was
doing it but when it went so well i
thought i was a guy a little cocky you
know first show cockies and uh so the
next night the next week that they let
me on was like three weeks later that's
how good the set was and uh
and uh so then i tell all my friends and
everybody you know come on out this is
amazing and i just went on stage and
drank a cup of my own warm [ __ ] sperm
this [ __ ] great comic salon right
before me i froze up and it was awful
just the worst thing i don't think
everything anything ever happened worse
after that that that set was so
absolutely horrible
that i was like and all my friends were
there they're like uh
and then your friends are trying to
laugh but it's really not funny so
they're making that
sound that's what my sister-in-law's
but it's not a laugh because you can't
if it's not funny you can't make
yourself [ __ ] laugh at it you just go
now what year was this
86 oh my and what was going on in the
comedy community then they were all over
the place comedy clubs no
no you don't know they were uh that was
pretty much the
80s
middle of the boom i guess you know
there were there was a
three there were four clubs and uh
and uh dallas
so uh i got i figured out
i'm i'm smart on a couple levels but one
of them is
i saw that was an emcee job not an
opening act job so
if you were really
dedicate yourself to becoming a
really good master of ceremonies even
though you suck if you're
if you're if you memorize the
announcements and you know who's coming
next week and you make it look like a
show
then you'll probably get more work than
these guys that are just back there
looking at their stupid little horrible
jokes and then they're like pulling out
pieces of paper and then
you know so i i'm like well you know
[ __ ] show business why not make it
slicker
maybe that helps to get you know stage
time because that's what you need it's
stage time you know how do you get on
stage how do you stay on stage how do
you where do you have to go to get on
stage what because if you're not willing
to do whatever the [ __ ] it takes
to stay on stage then
then you know it it won't work anyway
but it for sure won't work if you know
if you don't have that kind of you know
attitude or mentality of
you know i i would invent
things to put me on stage when i was an
amateur comic uh i would go to these
restaurants
or hotels of the restaurant and i would
set up a comedy competition
and first place would be dinner for two
and uh i would only invite comics that i
was funnier than if you were funnier
than me you weren't gonna hear about
this competition
because i wanted the [ __ ] food you
know and that meant something that was
like you know 16 worth of stuff and it
you know and a meal
uh
you know was [ __ ] that important it
meant something and and uh and
you know and so i just kind of learned
how to set up gigs that way
so now we're going to
talk a minute about i started talking
about the 300 bucks for first place and
200 bucks or whatever
and uh and then eventually i got good
enough anybody could come you know i
could you know
when did you start featuring how long
i uh i started featuring
uh
i got to i got a phone call one day
and uh
from the funny bone in arlington texas
and uh sam kennison was coming to the
uh dallas county convention theater for
a makeup show he'd already missed it
he'd already canceled it
and uh
so
and carl was uh carla bove was in
rehab and uh they really hadn't thought
about who was going to open the show
so they called the improv day of show
and then uh
and asked them you know who can we get
to do this and they go well ron white's
pretty funny and uh and i i i wish i
could tell you when it was but i think
maybe two years or a year and a half or
something i only had 15 minutes and it
was a 20-minute job so when they said 20
minutes i was like sure
and
so it wasn't very long get into it
and uh
i gotta go down there and uh with my uh
my first wife uh lori and uh and alex
ramundo um
uh my dear friend for 30 years to this
day we're gonna work together tomorrow
night or last week or whatever
and uh
so
so sam it's 2000 seats you know i hadn't
played more than funny bomb you know
that's all i'd played and uh
but they were packed and you know back
in the 80s and
and uh
so i
uh his brother was there uh i can't
remember his name now
uh kennison's brother was his manager
bill bill here at bill bill and uh
you know he's uh kid sam's not there
there's nobody else back there and when
they have us a six pack of beer and an
ice chest and
then sam has a dressing suite with a you
know bunch of stuff in it and uh and but
nobody's there and uh so he goes well
we're gonna go ahead and start the show
and he goes uh sam's
uh opening act is oft times a
sacrificial lamb
because sam was at his peak of uh
popularity and then and they he said
sometimes they'll just start yelling at
you
and trying to get you off stage and and
now they just want to see sam so
whatever happens don't take it [ __ ]
personal
and i was like okay okay all right okay
and uh and i go out there it was it was
the
it was the set was so strong that it
lasted
16 minutes you know it was only 14
minutes of stuff
but i murdered and uh just absolutely
killed and uh
and uh i was looking over the side i
know he was hoping i would do more time
because sam still wasn't there
and uh i'm like all right and the
[ __ ] crowd goes nuts and uh then
there's the people that some of the some
people that were owners of the funny
bone chain were at that show and some
people went from the
last stop or at that show
and uh
and i think the punchline also
and um
so anyway i come off stage and
sam's still not there so you know i'm
high-fiving uh lori and alex and that
was great that was cool that was murder
that's the best thing ever
and uh
we're back there drinking a six-pack of
budweiser and uh alex and i smoke a
joint
and all sudden three limbos pull up now
there's 20 people back there as soon as
he gets sam gets there he sends his
bodyguard to get me
and he goes uh mr kennison like to meet
you and so i go back in the back and uh
he's uh
there's two rooms in this little
dressing area and we and people in the
front and uh and then there was a
private room in the back and it's just
sam
and a hooker
i guess and
and uh and he's got a big old viola blow
and something there's a rock stuck in it
and he's just banging it on the table
he's working on it he's frustrated he
can't get what he wants out of the end
of this bottle
and then finally it it clumps up and he
got out of there a big whole pile and
he goes uh
heard you killed him cowboy
and i go yes i am as a great crowd
you're gonna have fun he goes
how about a cup of coffee
yeah yeah okay all right
and uh so we
both did a he did his monster rail and
blow and then and then faked a heart
attack
and nobody believed it but me
and uh but he did he [ __ ] he's on his
back grabbing his [ __ ] heart and just
[ __ ] shaking and then like
because i know i would have died if i'd
have done that one instead of the one i
did
and uh and then he hops up laughing and
uh
he goes let me show you how to do this
and he goes downstairs he just pounds
the [ __ ]
out of this crowd it was so beautiful to
see
and uh
and so afterwards
i had a a demon on each side the demon
and the devil the dead
no no no i had a demon and an angel
and the angel was uh all the
representatives from those clubs going
let's go out to dinner and we'll have uh
a nice discussion about your comedy
career
on one shoulder and the other shoulder
with kenneth and going let's go to a
teddy bar and store some cocaine and
i'm like i'll see you guys tomorrow
right so i just went with sam and uh
and i didn't see him again for years and
uh but that's
that was that's where i got the dates
to do 50 weeks you know enough to you
know pay the bills what year was that
about it
wow wow
yeah so yeah he was at the top of his
[ __ ] game yeah oh yeah good lord it
was amazing it was amazing to see you
know i i hadn't seen
uh
i don't think i had even seen well i
know i hadn't seen homo sexual
necrophilia
ever and uh
and he did it in that set and uh so it
was it was a new so it was a newer set
it was mostly stuff i hadn't seen but
uh back then it was pretty prolific with
uh what you know with that amazing stuff
yeah he built a bridge that a bunch of
comics walked across
and uh that bridge i'm good at naming
bridges and comedy and that was bridge
that people can genuinely find you
disgusting and you can still make them
laugh
and i don't think anybody knew that
before sam you know
sam was gut level [ __ ]
uh
uh
just unpleasant in his in his views and
his opinions and and uh
and
and but was such a gifted orator
that he could still [ __ ] hook you
into it even if you're like afterwards
you felt dirty about it i mean it's a
you know something you're really good at
too
i watched that i still remember not
doing comedy
just snorting blowing my living room on
a saturday night and i still remember
that bit he did about
uh why you you know shipping food there
right you're [ __ ] nothing grows lee
you know ron white's in studio drink
that [ __ ] drink i'm drinking it over
there put ice in it diluting it take a
shot columbus did it's always a fun you
know it's around the whites and it's
pretty much gone oh yeah this is number
one here
that now from there where the [ __ ] was
your head the next day you're like this
is it
there's no more working in a [ __ ] job
this deck that you know i i got uh i
wasn't really good at anything and uh at
all
and uh was also a little on the lazy
side
and uh
so uh i know it was horrible in high
school and uh i got kicked out in the
10th grade
and uh joined the navy and got kicked
out of the navy after 18 months because
i was horrible at that really mad at me
really about that
and um
you know i was just my brain just like i
i knew i wasn't stupid like everybody
claimed
because i knew that my brain had a
something and i was
something was there but it
was so unfucking defined i just couldn't
figure out what it was and
and uh so the
really the first time i went on stage i
was on stage going oh i'm a comedian
well that's [ __ ] good to know at
least i know it but i knew the first
time i walked on stage this is where it
fits this is exactly the puzzle piece
that fits the [ __ ] puzzle piece of my
brain and what it will do
uh so and you know whether i was born to
be a stand-up comic or it just happened
along or whatever
uh but uh
i would starve to death in any other
country on this planet with the skills
that i have but in in the us that makes
two of us
if it wasn't for
i thought when i came i came down here
only because of the pilot
they saw me in seattle
i didn't think i was good enough to live
in l.a i said that it's not gonna work
and i said i'll give myself a year if
this fails i moved to jersey and just
sell drugs i've done it all i've been a
chef at [ __ ] wendy's
i was ever i couldn't do it
yeah i was a chef with wendy's
i was in the chef training program okay
but you know i just fit when i got on
stage i knew i didn't want to work
things
my mom owned the bar and her days were
free and i loved her lifestyle
she worked from eight to three and that
was a great lifestyle yeah right she
went there in the daytime she looked at
the receipts
she talked to a few people and then she
was on her way to a mech game getting
[ __ ] lit go home cook dinner we
dinner abandon ship go to the bar work
until three i always knew i was not
gonna get a day job it just wasn't gonna
work i tried the bartending who the [ __ ]
wants to bartend you want to be on the
other side of the bar drink it for free
there's no better job you know you know
alex i mentioned alex earlier his the
reason he decided to go into stand-up
was he was working as a bartender at the
club
and uh
he had to go do something at the condo
and the guys were at the pool on a
wednesday
and just floating there chatting up the
chicks and uh
you know this and he's like that's what
i want to do i want to lay by the pool
on wednesday not get up and drive
someplace
i was a failure i knew it wasn't going
to work ron mueller i knew it wasn't
going to work let me ask you this i know
it's an offsetting question that guy
that talked into going down there you
still communicate with him
yeah
sam lazy is that yeah no no sam is a
great guy i always i always thought he'd
be a horrible salesman and he was like
way better than me and i was pretty good
and uh
but uh yeah i uh i bought him an advice
he liked a cross-country bicycle and i
had this big you know part of big right
you know group of people that did it and
so i bought him uh
the the
most ridiculous bicycle ever
and uh and i bailed him out of jail a
couple of times
so yeah we stay in contact he actually
usually when i played he still lives
right where he used to same house so
whenever i play fort worth and dallas or
what he always comes out to show the
first guy that it was
the first guy that ever mentioned stand
up to me i was working at
hollister chrysler plymouth snort and
coke seven days a week
you know making seven eight grand a
month selling cars out there with a suit
on thinking you're [ __ ] john gotti
but i was snorting all night every night
till six
then i went with the bill crouch subaru
like the third day there was a new
manager there and we actually bumped
[ __ ] heads
like it was like [ __ ] you i do it this
way he's like [ __ ] you i do it this way
and this guy got in my face and i got in
his face
and like two days later we got we got
broken up that night and two days later
i'm outside waiting for a custom and
this crazy [ __ ] comes up to me and goes
hey man
i don't know what happened between us
the other day no do i care i know you
maybe not like you i'm not too crazy
about you he goes but
for ten years of my life i was an
assistant to an entertainment director
in vegas
and he goes i'll tell you something you
don't need to be selling cars you could
be a stand-up comic
i'm like go [ __ ] yourself you just call
me a [ __ ] loser two days ago
now you're telling me you could be a
stand-up well you could be a stand-up
comic and a loser yeah yeah
so it's those i never know i always sit
there for nights
thinking about what his name is and i
still i would love to see him
and give him a hug and go you were
[ __ ] right that was the first
then other people came along and said
different things you in that direction
now from all right so now you're a
feature act you're out there i start
comedy in 91
for three years i just sell volumes i
told my friends come to my show they
would call me and go you got to grandma
blow yeah show up at the broker it's
there and they would come and now they'd
have to go to the genius man oh my god
that's that's how you get people to
shows right it makes you uh regional oh
my god regional distributor i would tell
them you want to have grandma give it to
you for 45 it's one rock but you got to
come to the broker at 8 30. why what's
going on just show up there i'll meet
you there they would walk in they'd pay
the [ __ ] finals to get in
they'd sit through the show i'd do the
comedy and then i'd give them the coke
or the valiums
what a
couple 94 i got into it
96 i finally start going on the road to
different places 97
coconut grove has a club
i keep calling this club going i'm cuban
i want to work the club i worked it a
lot go [ __ ] yeah i know and go [ __ ]
yourself you can't work down here
then finally that [ __ ] uh the chinese
hot piece of ass sarah and i called me
and she goes i got a week for you two
weeks you gotta do buffalo first then
i'll give you miami that was alex's girl
yeah that was alex's girl from the first
night before buffalo i booked a [ __ ]
pennzoil commercial a mobster was the
heat of mafia [ __ ] because the sopranos
i'm going on every day on a different
commercial i book up around the world
type of pennzoil commercial
i call sarah knight at eight o'clock at
night l.a time i go sarah buffalo ain't
gonna happen on tuesday morning
she goes don't ever call me again i'm
like [ __ ]
[ __ ] i just lost miami a year later they
called again and go
we want you down in miami i gotta tell
you around when the [ __ ] minute i
walked in everybody kept asking me do
you know where i went
are you friends with runway i saw your
picture on the wall i don't know this
[ __ ] guy
that went on and they loved you down
there this is a cuban club
yeah yeah and they loved you i worked
that international crowd pretty well you
know that
it's uh it was and i also participated
in the
fun i i watched people age at an
accelerated rate at that [ __ ] club so
when that parking lot
first opened everybody was [ __ ] the
guys were [ __ ] the girls were
[ __ ] well everybody was cute
but you're they're going at it on this
blow they're getting for almost nothing
every night every single night and i
would only be there for like five days
so i would take a hit
but i'd come back a year and i didn't do
a lot of blow outside of there i mean i
did some you know i didn't blow but i
didn't i wasn't i didn't hit it as hard
as you did oh i was hitting it and uh
but when i was down there i would
[ __ ] go
we spent
we went to
i don't know why i was just someone to
do the stupidest [ __ ] when i'm wired but
uh
everybody wants to go see rupaul at this
huge gay bar
he
plays like 2 000 gay men
and uh rupaul comes in and does like he
had he had like a song of a hit song on
the radio and uh
he does that song and then does it it's
great to be gay [ __ ] and uh their
cheerleader stuff and all these guys
and the reason i really remember it is
because like the ugliest dudes there hit
on me and i'm like
what
you're not gonna send your little rob
low looking [ __ ] over here what
what what i i know i'm kind of fat but
god damn i'm not going to [ __ ] you
everybody this is not going to crack the
[ __ ]
safe
now what was the whole mexico thing
why were you living in mexico
[ __ ] and people look every comedy
club is looking for you yeah
it was
yeah
it's
you know i was
i was with her with a girl living on a
lake outside of austin and uh
and the funny bone comedy club
realized they could [ __ ] me
uh because they realized that
i had so many eggs in their basket that
they didn't need to pay me two grand a
week in air
that they could pay me 1500 and drop the
air so that's a big cut and pay so it
cost you about 280 to you know fly
around to a gig something like that and
i was living in south texas
and uh
or i've lived in austin
lake
kingsland texas
and my girlfriend made this uh pottery
it was really pretty as mosaic tile
application to an existing piece of
pottery you sell it in art shows but it
takes like six months to make enough to
sell in a day so
i just started thinking well you know
you go down to mexico you know hire a
room full of people
and uh teach them how to do this and uh
so i
i sold the house and
loaded all my stuff up in a big uh
biggest thing writer's sales and then my
van pulling the biggest trailer that
they've rent i mean rent
and we traipse off down to mexico i
don't speak spanish i don't know anybody
and uh
first we get a a trailer
uh outside in mcallen texas
and it was like a it was like a gated
golf course trailer park
uh so it was kind of like a high-end
trailer living
uh but it was my but my love was for
reynos from mexico i mean i loved it
over there i used to play a comedy club
down in mcallen and i'd go over there
and you know [ __ ] [ __ ] and whatever
you know texas [ __ ] you know and uh
that's where it's what you're doing
where you go
so i always had a you know like a warm
spot in my heart for it
and uh
so um
you know i go over there and meet this
lady named aaron munoz and uh
and uh who speaks a little bit
of uh english and uh
so i do exactly what i envisioned that
was you know we
hired these ladies that live in this
colonia and i've rented this
uh
uh run down old tortilla factory and
cleaned it up and painted it and [ __ ]
and
built tables myself i was in there
sweating you know drinking corona and
smoking weed that i had to smuggle
from the u.s back into mexico i was the
only one going that way with weed
and so i got away with it but i
literally didn't have any idea where to
buy marijuana in mexico because they
don't smoke marijuana in the border
towns i mean yeah not very many people
do
so the dealers on the other side so you
got to bring it back it seemed kind of
funny
and uh
but anyway
it was uh
it was uh
you know it was just a red experience my
son you know i had joint custody of my
son so from the time i'd been doing
standing for three years i had a
three-year-old four you know my son was
with me half the time so i'm in a van
with a car seat i don't know jack [ __ ]
about raising a kid but i got part of
one i got it and uh
yeah
and uh so uh you know
and you know every whenever i'm supposed
to have him you know his mother puts him
on the plane send him to mexico
and uh and she was always hip about it
you know it was probably a good
experience for him so
and uh
but
eventually
the uh blue you know i started i'm going
out on the weekends with jeff and that's
so i'd get on a plane fly from a cow
into
uh
to uh
houston and then i get off from houston
to atlanta and then jeff was leasing
jets by then and uh
and then we go do
you know probably three cities in three
days and it was just you and jeff then
just me and jeff okay
and what year is this let's pretend yeah
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] 93 maybe 93.94
uh so and then every once in a while i'm
doing a pub i mean i have a club
somebody that didn't try to [ __ ] me over
and uh
and and then also when i told the people
at the funny bone to go eat a steaming
bowl of [ __ ]
six months later they were going well
wait a minute you know we'll pay you the
money and then so then you know i'm
working with jeff and
so jeff's paying me 1500 a show
uh
so that's way more money and he did it
because he loved me and he knew i needed
it you know so he [ __ ]
great guy
and uh
so
now i can find the company down there
and uh so i go out with him and i'll fly
back on sunday
and uh
you know go back and uh
live a life i love which was down in uh
mexico
nobody bothers you yeah no no i can't i
always wanted to live in mexico like
well a bamboo went for the tattoo
yeah right that morning and [ __ ]
[ __ ] teepee i lost my virginity
to a prostitute in tijuana when i was 18
years old in the navy
she was uh overweight and her
teeth had no general direction or color
but she was well within my budget
is that why you got kicked out of the
navy
oh no
cause you you said i and i just never
heard that before that you're bad at the
navy
i've never heard like i don't like i
think i'd be bad in the navy really for
different reasons really bad at the navy
uh
i uh
you know i just had this uh
i had this thing with drugs
uh you know from the you know i grew up
in uh from a little bitty town but i
grew up in houston so we had uh plenty
of
uh
you know
just you know hey ashbury was going on
in
l.a but alan's landing was going on and
there were eight aspects in
frisco but right and then allen's
landing in houston was going on
and which was a huge hippie scene in
houston and uh and my parents
would take it i mean it was literally
daisies in your hair big ass people
tripping their [ __ ] brains out just
wandering around acting goofy
and my parents used to take us down
there to look at them like they were zoo
animals
and uh i was like well it looks like
they're having fun
it was like a learning moment like don't
end up like these people or yeah so
you know i had a
uh
just an odd childhood you know that uh
for one you know i mean chasing lizards
in this little bitty dirt town that's uh
and then uh then i live in houston in a
you know in a time where you know the
america is probably it's one of its most
interesting periods politically and
socially and
it was pretty goddamn cool and uh but i
always had i always lean towards uh
drugs pretty heavy
you know
amounts of drugs why we talk to each
other and that doesn't work in uh the
navy my handle on the cb was captain
cannabinol
where were you stationed in the navy
i was uh stationed at uh
pearl harbor
and uh
so we went on a western pacific cruise
and then i got i got busted uh they had
a drug test on our boat now you know
eight of us out of only 76 people on
this boat and they that was got busted
for heroin
and uh
they really took it seriously and you
know what the thing is it was either
heroin or huff paint because i just like
getting [ __ ] up
and uh in the heroine that we were
snorting and it was like a match head of
it would get eight people so [ __ ] up
they couldn't [ __ ] see
and i liked it like i was like i was
like clapton
and uh so but but it never was a big
junkie you know i got busted there and
then i got sent to the naval drug
rehabilitation center in miramar
california
and uh
and there i got discharged from the navy
and the
uh the the commander of the base uh
miramar
while i was being discharged uh called
me a hole in our national line of
defense i'm like me i'm
19.
what were you counting on me for for
[ __ ]
a whole that's
an insult
but
and where did you grow up what what city
houston you said yeah yeah so you went
from houston to 19 in hawaii
it's amazing you only did a little bit
like that seems like
heaven well we did what we started doing
uh
i started doing acid in uh in a school
and
uh then it's probably 75
and the first time i did it i was in a
school in san diego
and uh this guy was selling this win to
paying acid that i had no idea what i
had in my hand and i
they were just buying the barracks down
below me
and uh
but i did have a tendency to like pills
and stuff so i was like yeah [ __ ] i'll
try it and i but i didn't have any
friends i mean i just got there and
so i took two hits of uh this four wave
so this is eight hits of
this sick ass uh windowpane acid
and i loved it i mean i just i was
[ __ ] up i did 178.
i was in the eighth grade and i was
[ __ ] up ron white yeah yeah i i had a
dad had this trip so it was so
part of it was really awkward because i
was in this hotel and i rented and i'm
laying on this couch tripping my brains
i don't even know what's happening you
know but i don't know it's it's pleasant
for the most part and i don't have to do
anything except enjoy it because i'm in
a hotel room and uh with a couple other
people
and uh
and so i started getting this uh
this
vision of me inflating
and uh and i would take my shoes off and
i would deflate a little bit
and then i'd get too thin and i'd put my
shoes back on and i'd start to inflate a
little bit more so for hours i just
every 15 minutes i got to take my shoes
off or
put them back on to keep me from getting
too thin or too fat it was pretty strong
acid is what i'm trying to say
at least it made sense at the time but
yeah it was manageable
it was manageable it was a management i
even got the sugar cubes
and the liquid acid old school style we
did it one time we did it more than once
what did we do we do it two nights in a
row that's right
we just did it light though it wasn't
really deep deep deep
seen [ __ ] leprechauns and stuff like
this now
so you're in mexico and you're still
traveling from time to time but nobody's
got your [ __ ] phone number
yeah so finally i go to miami and i meet
this character named joe chadwick
and i went in there as a feature and i
worked the first week and they really
liked me then the second week that
somebody dropped out and they kept me
the first time i was there i went for
three weeks straight
but the three weeks i was there they
took about two people you
and a white guy from cleveland
that's still in the game something
happened i think he works locally in
cleveland whatever
never knew who this was i go back there
again
new year's i do all these gigs and
they're talking to me about this
character named ron white and finally i
go back to l.a and one day my phone
starts ringing do i know how to get a
hold of ron white
and i'm laughing my ass off i'm like
giggling
and i never think anything of it i never
see this character run white
and i go to the [ __ ] laugh factory in
houston which at the time
had to be one of the best clubs in the
country
the place where i always had the best
time in my life was that city
and i go there and i think it's john
wesley and me and we go out to smoke a
joint and there you are kathleen's
headlining you're featuring
and you're outside holding court man
just talking about
i'm watching you
and then i sat there and watched you
before kathleen and i was just [ __ ]
blown the [ __ ] away
that [ __ ]
landing in uh uh where i oded with iod
beaumont
international airport entire server i
[ __ ] i almost i almost [ __ ] passed
out beaumont was where i almost do deed
[ __ ] who ods
in beaumont nobody's isn't that where uh
jenna's job janet's job and that's where
she was from yeah that's where she was
from the museum is
the worst museum in the world
and i fell in love with you after that i
was like wait a second i gotta do
something about my stand up there were
two people that when i watched live
influence my standup the first guy was
doug stanhope in 96
in uh seattle i i thought i got hit like
i i considered quitting the next day uh
that's like i still consider quitting
when i watch stay at home i consider
quitting the next day like i got to
either do that yeah he's way better than
me and then i saw you in houston 99 2000
and you just had what i needed
you had the essence of i don't give a
[ __ ] if you laugh
i'm here to have a few drinks
smoke a few joints if i bump into a line
and a [ __ ]
that's like the cherry on the sundae
yeah and i'm like that's where you have
to be in comedy
you can't go i was a philandering yeah i
admit that you can't go up there
thinking about you got a bomb who gives
a [ __ ]
just go up there and be you and that i
wanted to tell you that that's why i
wanted you
to come on the show because that in 2000
when i came back to l.a i was a complete
different comic
because i knew it wasn't up to the
audience
it was up to [ __ ] me right and i got
that from you that's what i you know
tell people that
if you look at the
common denominator
of all uh
you know uh great comics which you are
i don't know if you know this but uh you
go watch joey uh shake a crowd he can
take him by the i can just shake them
and it doesn't matter if there's 50 of
them or 5 000 of them that there's
nobody better at this than you and uh
you know you're rogan's favorite comic
and uh and and i i watched the other day
it was like he had this crowd rock and
that's the main that's a fun [ __ ] you
get them rocking just boom boom boom
boom boom boom just slapping them in the
face and
you know it's really fun to watch but
it's also 20 years ron white and i want
young comics to understand that right
maybe 30 i'm 27 and 27 yeah i'm not 27.
this year yeah
july i'm like 82 in cocaine years
you ever get like yeah i'm like 87 and
cocaine years
but
the 20-year mark really
makes you decide something and for me
that's what it was now i think july 18th
was 28 years it was 91.
so whatever 91
2001 2011 27 years
so when did the whole [ __ ]
tour start
like i'm i think around 2000
or maybe it was uh 99
i'd been opening for jeff
for a few years and uh
and then uh one day we were on the plane
and he starts telling me about this
concept because the king's comedy which
was essentially entertainer and uh
you know i feel like an idiot
uh the the the the quit the game show
host
and the guy who died bernie mac and uh
bernie mac yes right and uh
god so steve harvey yes
which makes me a
horrible [ __ ] comedian for not being
able to pull those names out but
so they're doing huge numbers and uh as
as a group of four touring comics and so
you know of course we like see what the
black man does well
and we steal that and uh so we we form
our group and
and um
and he tells me about it and then
you know so it was just going to be a
kind of a rural version of that you know
southern version of that kind of that
same marketing you know except for the
only star is one is jeff
but he's bigger than all those guys uh
jeff
we're smaller than all those guys so
you know who knows how it's going to
work and
so uh
jeff tells me about it i said that's
[ __ ]
so that's that's what a seer i am and
then uh that's what you need four comics
for that's against the rules nobody does
that
so uh
so we did it and you know it was the
biggest uh
comedy tour in the history of spoken
word by a lot and then dvd sales into
the millions and millions of millions
the first one sold four million copies
and that made me a
no i've never been a household name i'm
not one now
uh yes my fame came from you know i'm
not either i'm telling you i'm not
that's i have fans that's gray
but i'm not a household name because my
fan my fame doesn't come from television
it comes from stand-up comedy that's i'm
a famous comedian that's it
i don't
you know
i don't have the exposure of some of
these guys that have it doesn't matter i
don't care it doesn't matter
you're a [ __ ] stand up that's like
now it's all i ever wanted to be i found
out i was one and i kept being it
and uh
anyway i [ __ ] i forgot what i was
talking about what's up
just the red the
blue color the blue color
red color [ __ ] blue so it was so huge
and then uh
and then you know we we put out that uh
warner brothers agreed to turn it into a
movie
and it was really kathleen that was
telling me do you have any idea how big
a deal that is that warner brothers is
going to take your image
and put it in theaters and dvds and
whatever the hell i was like no it
sounds great you know i don't know
probably won't happen but
they say the deal's already done
so sure enough you know i'm doing
i'm opening for this you know group of
comics so i'm doing 10-minute sets and
and so i'm up and that's all i'm doing
to open this one's 10 minutes and i'm a
at that time i would consider myself one
of the best
10-minute
big venue comics in the country because
nobody did it more than i did and i was
comfortable doing it so it and that
opened in the show and it was you know
it was all set up so perfectly and
and then i came back at the end and did
a story that i've been telling for years
and uh that always kills and i'm like
i'm set to i'm set to pop that [ __ ]
tater just set them up it was like the
eight ball lee you're ready for a star
absolutely i know you had that star look
on your face
you're like when is joey going to offer
me a
because i'm sitting here going you know
what
this tequila might set the [ __ ] star
that that would be perfect
i have no idea what's going on you never
had a star in there no nothing i'm
saying no i got hey i got a set to do
dude oh no this ain't for you oh okay
thank god this is for me and lee this is
just but i'll let you guys hear what
it's at tonight no i'll give you one to
go all right
that's for you my brother how good i'm
going
in other words that's the
last layer that i'm one state
all right it's 125 milligrams it's that
that's it that's all you need is 125
milligrams that's it
that's all you need
what am i supposed to do with it eat it
put it in my pocket i can't eat it i
gotta you save it i give a piece of
paper on the way out so how pissed do
you think it'd be if i [ __ ]
didn't go do a set tonight i just tell
them you got [ __ ] caught up
you bumped into a bottle of tequila by
mistake
yeah i'll be i'll be there i'm going to
be [ __ ] toasted though
you know random one it's just uh
now how old were you when all this was
going on i started when i was 29
and no the the the blue collar tour
however uh about 45 about uh when it
started so that
uh
so i'd been doing stand-up for about 15
years and
and uh
and then it's been 15 years since then
so it would have been 2002 i guess or
2001. and how many years did you guys
did you guys continue that tour that was
like a four-year talk correct it was we
did it for you know we we toured for
like three years and uh then we got the
the last two movies that we did put out
were uh we weren't touring together we
just acted like we were we were all out
doing our stuff last
i started making so much money it was it
was uh
ridiculous in that
i mean i really couldn't believe it i
mean if you can sell out a theater
uh and you're a comedian and it doesn't
cost anything to produce it you ride it
there's no backup band there's no
18-wheeler full of [ __ ] out there
it is you left on stage telling jokes i
really never even considered how much
money you could make doing it at that
level
and uh
you know i
it it
changed the whole way
that uh
you know that i've
you know perceive life and live my life
and and uh and i didn't see it coming
and i never sat around thinking it might
i never thought you know someday i'm
going to be a huge you know economy star
and i'll be rich as [ __ ] and i'll have a
jet at the airport and
uh
you know i never ever thought about that
kind of stuff and uh
and uh
you know and then it uh and then it and
it happened so that's that's called fame
and fortune
so now people know who i am i was way
more famous than no two i think that i
am now because that all those dvds were
out and you know every day you're not on
television you're less famous than you
were the day before
and uh which followed me that's right
you're still one of the funniest guys
working today man that's all that
matters that's why you got into this in
the first place
was to just be funny yeah yeah that's
all i wanted to do
and i was always true to it and true to
my nature you know that anyway i think
that's what i was trying to say before i
turned into this [ __ ] does that sound
braggadocious no i don't mean i don't
mean for it too not at all not mean to
be vulnerable by saying it you know that
just how much
we made
i'll tell you that
i would made the one week i made 3 000
bucks and uh
or 3 500 in a comedy club for i think i
was just there for the weekend so that
was more money than i was making before
and uh
but not as much as i was making while we
were touring as i was their opening act
at the
blue collar i was making more but that
ended
so uh
then uh the the uh dvd went kind of
straight to
to movie i mean straight or the move dvd
went straight to dvd it didn't stay in
the theaters very long what a successful
theater release
and uh
so i'm back at the omaha funny bone you
know making a little more money but you
know but it looks like it missed you
know it looked like a mess
and uh
but
you're still doing tedious today though
me yeah oh yeah yeah okay there's no
more omaha funny about oh god there
hadn't been a noble health funny bone in
15 years i'm going there in november i'm
not there's nothing wrong with it i'm
not saying no i've been and she loves
you too yeah yeah she's a good lady the
cat in the hat that's what i call her
she never tell you the story when i went
she woke me up to go to radio like you
think we got time to [ __ ] and this is
the woman that owns the club i'm like
so
kind of colleen drago
good lady yeah she's a sweetheart i love
her
so anyway i don't remember what i'm
talking about we're just talking about
where you were
and how fast you moved up in a short
period of time which you [ __ ] can't
believe you're waiting for a building to
fall on top of your head well they i'll
tell you the the weekend that that made
me realize it and uh
and
in dollars and cents
uh i made thirty five hundred 500
and then i had
this little theater 800 seat theater in
atlanta that i wanted to do instead of
the comedy club because that guy [ __ ]
me out of money
and uh
and by then i'm selling out these clubs
but my
my manager says no you need to do club
one more time really solidify yourself
and then go to theaters i'm like i think
this will work
so
i sell out nine of them in uh in in five
days and make ninety thousand dollars
and uh and i was like the the whole
night at that time i was like so
what am i
how am i trying to make equipment
because they're just selling out boom
boom gone gone gone oh god i have no
idea
it literally brings me to tears
uh of just realizing that this is going
on then we put a show on sale in
minneapolis it sells out in two minutes
two minutes after we put it on sale you
couldn't get a ticket for it and uh and
at that time
for a
an ever so
short amount of time i was probably the
hottest comic in the world and
and uh and
i just gone now i'm selling out i mean
back i mean like a month later once we
figure out how big it is now i'm putting
they're putting me in these huge rooms
and
uh making i'm bringing i'm not making
but bringing in
you know three and four and five hundred
thousand dollars a week
and uh
and
it's and then now all of a sudden
you know it's fame and fortune it's not
it there are
pitfalls and booby traps and nothing's
real and
you know that uh and you know i fell for
all of it you know
i was
you know i wrote it out
so i mean look who we were look where
you were you had to write it out ron
white what were your options
all right go back to mexico and just
make lenovo i just kept uh you know i
kept doing stand-up and
and uh realized that this this was it
was such a validation it made stand-up
fun
and it is to this day you know i think
if it wouldn't have you know had that
successful element to it i don't know
that i would still be
uh well probably would probably even
more but uh you know
so in love with stand up to this day
that i
you know when i'm in town instead of
staying in my house i you know i go down
there and be a stand-up comedian and if
you want to be a stand-up comic that's
all you got to do is go be a stand-up
comic but you have to do that you got to
go be one it's funny i when i sit there
and watch you on stage
i get that vibe from you
that you're very [ __ ] happy
to be a standpoint you have a great job
yeah who wouldn't
you know and i do these shows for
nothing i don't even get my 35 dollars
or whatever it is
yeah whatever i don't collect it i'm
like i don't have the time
but i i saw it you know those are the
shows i do way more shows for nothing
than i do for money
and uh so
the it's you know
the touring schedule now is still 110
cities a year
and uh you know that's that's i still
play the you know
the same rooms that uh now burr sells
these rooms out four times a night and
uh sebastian their lineup down at the
[ __ ] comedy store is so goddamn
pretty strong
if you're a comic looking at that list
the best thing you can hope for is to
follow me
because everybody else is so strong it's
just you know it's it's amazing
i followed ali wong the other night and
i was like allie wong everybody if she
was only a little more confident
it's a couple weeks ago i said [ __ ] two
or three months ago i can't go down
there no more
because i can't work out i can't just go
up there with a note and a piece of
paper and work out
so i would go hide at the haha and
[ __ ] flappers which is great
but then i started thinking i'm like
[ __ ] it i'm just taking my road show to
the store that's what got me here
that was [ __ ] dude that's what i do
yeah i can't follow these [ __ ]
i thought of yesterday i'm there to
murder i mean is that what we're doing
that [ __ ] crystal here
you ever try to follow that lunatic
talking about possums in his backyard
and whatnot oh yeah there's a couple
people up there that you gotta follow
that you go i'm just gonna do the best i
can right
right that's why they're cause they're
so good man it's kind of i don't know
it's harder than the weekends i don't
even know the comedy's been uh in better
shape than it is right this minute you
know with
you know even with uh with rogan you
know i watch rogan on stage and uh and
he does you know do old tons of new
stuff and and
you know i think i think maybe
pound for pound he's you know maybe my
favorite comic right now he is
great guy he writes uh
you know you went out with
uh
in the beginning
madigan no the guy you we were talking
about alex
no foxworthy oh faculty and i'm sure
that 30 of the stuff you do on the road
today
is things you learned on the road with
foxworthy well you know what foxworthy
the first time i ever did stand-up he
was at the show that's how influential
jeff is for me
and important he is to me
he comes up to me after the set
because he was the headliner in the club
that week just by [ __ ] chance that i
mean all these things came together over
the years and all this stuff you know
and
and uh
but uh he came up to me after the set
and my first set ever and he goes you're
really funny but you need to put the
punch line at the end of the joke
and i was like what and
so this is how generous this
[ __ ] is
he sits down with a comic that's done
four
[ __ ] minutes of stand-up comedy
and teaches me something about structure
you know just that you can say this part
of this sentence here
but if you don't and you move that part
of the sentence to here then the punch
lines at the end of the joke and you
don't step on the lap and i was like
oh
oh so now i you know i've done it for 30
years so i can't imagine but so you
can't teach somebody funny at all but
you can teach them structure structure
absolutely you know and so you know he's
he's he was my mentor
even though i'm older than him i think
so that's uh kind of
disheartening when you're you have a
younger mentor but uh fox i had the same
situation on rogan
30 40 of what i do on the road right now
is the roadblocks and the
up and downs i learned on the road with
rogan
same thing i fly out the first flight
out i fly off the first flight in
i don't really do i mean there's just so
many things and it works you learn a lot
from
the guys that take you on the road it's
like you learn your
in and out you make it better
you make it better how to work for you
yeah it's a it's it's such a
you know there's
there's a million ways to skin a cat and
uh but and stand-up comedy
when people ask for advice you know i
just tell them that the journey's so
personal
that you can't tell someone how to do it
you don't even know how you did it
much less tell somebody else how to do
it because when somebody sends you a
tape and goes and you judge this
are you [ __ ] crazy
how who the [ __ ] am i to tell you what
your stand-up is right and for sure you
don't want me doing it no no no no
is it kind of weird because
like just thinking about you saying how
you went from right like the clubs to
the theaters your act didn't necessarily
change but the paycheck changes like in
every other job like your position or
your title changes a little bit and your
rate goes up but this you could do the
same thing on monday and tuesday and it
could be for 90 000 and for 15 bucks
yeah
the uh
i mean i you know i'm just
i i genuinely don't mean to sound
braggadocious because i don't even say
those numbers very often but that's what
happened
you know that's what happened and uh and
uh you know
i i
i uh but i genuinely didn't i didn't
really didn't see it coming i never
thought sat around and thought you know
that this was my ship is going to come
right i never thought that i was like
maybe something neat will happen
and i'll not go to jail some more and
you know maybe i can quit doing drugs
every day and you know do stand up and
and uh you know for some reason it all
[ __ ] shined
and uh and and and the success of it you
know left me in [ __ ] rehab and
you know
[ __ ] i was spinning out of control
when you gave me all the money i wanted
i'm [ __ ] living at the peninsula in a
suite
you know [ __ ]
2500 hookers doing blow like crazy
that's the most blow i ever did was that
point in my life you don't do blow
anymore
that's just a different different dark
man to bump into it
that's a different savage when you're
doing something but luckily i had a
therapist and he was able to talk me out
of a you know
maybe it wouldn't hurt if you just went
to this five-star rehab thing for 30
days and they've got really nice sheets
and a great chef and i was like that
doesn't sound too bad
so i went down there
that lasted for six months which wasn't
bad it was good six months you went to a
rehab for six months no i went there for
one month
but i stayed sober for six months i
i call it a
i had a brief bout with sobriety that
that i was able to overcome with the
help of my friends and my family what
was the main
uh drug of choice when you went to the
rehab scotch and
uh you know just massive amounts of
scotch and weed and you know but not a
lot of uh
and
that's pretty much it you know i i did
other drugs but i've kind of left all
that stuff out but
but i'm such a raging alcoholic that you
know it's just every once in a while you
gotta reel it in a little bit you know
so i love that white label on the rocks
when i was snorting blow in the 80s
that was my i said it like a dj dude
listen there's my first love affair
there was no [ __ ] for me
that [ __ ] dude is on the rocks with a
couple ice cubes
with a couple of lines of coke and a
coiled
your dick showed up you bad and [ __ ] too
oh my god you're a dick shot like a
[ __ ] marine just a little bit of each
other oh that was my love
that was when i was the craziest there
was a drink in the early 80s that used
to make me go crazy and you're gonna
remember it it was called harvey's
bristol cream it had no alcohol in it
but they put cosby pills in it because
every time i drank it with a girl with
the weirdest things happen
they want me to sniff their [ __ ] it
was always something do they still make
harvey's bristol cream i remember that
that name but i don't think i ever oh my
god it was terrible i think it was like
if i accidentally eat this [ __ ] star
i'm gonna be pissed dude nah don't be
busy it's gonna be a good time no i
gotta do a set
oh yeah they still make it
i think it's a dessert one i think there
might have been alcohol in it how much
alcohol let's find out
it's an original cream sherry oh my god
i used to get [ __ ] up i would get an
eight ball and take this little freak
down to seaside heights in jersey
and we'd get a two or three bottles of
harvey's bristol cream
my dick would get hard like hitler and
i'd eat that ass like it was going out
of style you understand he didn't even
know what to do harvey's bristol
one night i tied her up i got violent i
tied her up with the sheets and
next morning she's like what got into it
was harvey
oh my god it has it has a big one what
is it 17.5 isn't that a big one you get
[ __ ] up on that stuff all right most
sherry's never mind hold on that's most
sherry's have it i thought you said he
was a genius
no nobody said you just gave me that
star
uh it doesn't say how many it says most
wines are about
to run away when you came in
you said you're happy this all happened
because you had dick saved up for
retirement
you know i heard uh
i heard chris rock say some really uh
pretty poignant [ __ ] about stand-up
comic could be the comedy if you get the
chris rock talking about this art form
and the business of it and stuff he's
you know he's a smart smart guy but
he was talking about his biggest fear is
to lose it you know all the money that
he'd made because and people have lost
bigger fortunes than that you know this
is not this didn't dick what i've done
compared to what other people have lost
you know just in bad business and you
know people [ __ ] them over or
whatever and you've got how much dane
cook rob get robbed for by his brother
ten million dollars after tax money
that's that's a hundred million dollars
in ticket sales to put 10 in the bank
that's the way it works
at that level and he got
and i never you know i never really knew
him
and uh but i never thought he was funny
and and uh i mean i but literally i
bought his album listen to it one time
on the way home from the place i bought
it from
and i and and i got home and i threw it
away because i just don't i'm not a
collector of anything you know but so i
was like or whatever you know but it was
selling like crazy and it did i always
had an album that was selling and uh
this one just blew by me like a rocket
ship and i'm like what the [ __ ] is that
and so i went i didn't i maybe i just
don't get it
i mean sometimes i don't get it you know
but this is a real thing but i don't get
it
you know
it's like me with satellite live as a
kid i didn't get it i still don't get it
at times
people love it but i don't get it you
want some mice
uh
i gotta go drinking man
text that dude because it's uh
it's nine o'clock already i want you to
be at tip top magoo it's 8 55.
so can we get a volunteer to take my car
to the uh
no you guys are [ __ ] up you can't do
it oh my god yeah i'm [ __ ] up you
wanna get your special uber driver no
cause i don't wanna leave my car over
here
okay i'll drive it no don't drive it i
think hey look
we we look how much tequila we've got
there's two fingers left in there
there's two fingers of tequila and lee
still hasn't done the second glass
no he hasn't he put water in there he
milked it
i've been watching you look at the way
like the stars who puts [ __ ] water in
tequila [ __ ] 12 years in the
[ __ ] case i put like half a cup in my
knee i had a lot of [ __ ] alcohol it's
good it's good look at the bottle we
filled it i had like nine glasses here
oh delicious though no delicious it
really
really really really really uh great you
know when i went to pee
i noticed i didn't have that drunk
feeling i had more of that
whatever type feeling it's it's fun to
drink it's like it's uh it gets you a
little warm but it's not like you're
gonna
i don't know like when i was young i
only used to drink a certain kind of
tequila because it i could feel the burn
i was like oh yeah it burns like that
has to be good now i'm like oh yeah you
could just drink it over ice yeah
it's made wrong tequila does not have to
burn at all this is the smoothest stuff
in the world what made you invest in all
this
uh
well i would
invest
you know number one
i'm impetuous
and i'm an idiot
and uh and that's worked out you know so
i don't really put a lot of thought into
the things i do
you know uh
i guess and uh but but i knew this
tequila was amazing and uh
you know my and alex ramundo who i
started doing stand-up with
uh he's from mexico and he found it in
this little dusty distillery and he
brought me down there
and uh it's generally made
in the
in the shittiest [ __ ] distillery ever
anywhere in the world it's a genuine
[ __ ] it's like near but that's what
makes it this good
what makes it good is the rubescus
family been doing this for 140 years and
they make this craft tequila that's a
small batch thing and
and
we talked it took alex four years once
we decided that we wanted to try to let
bring it to the u.s because it's never
been here and
took him four years to convince him to
let us do it and uh
so
you know
it's
you know this is just a it's a it'll
it'll kill me i guarantee you because i
can't leave it alone i just got it needs
a like a goalie or something in front of
it after you've been drinking it for a
while because if you don't drink it on
the rocks how else can you drink you
like margaritas with it i mean
not this extra inejo now the other two i
mean the reposado and there's a blanco
and the blanco
the reposado's so good i wouldn't but
you know i rarely put even ice on this
just uh i usually just drink it out of
the bottle i don't use a glass it
it tastes delicious yeah
so it's called number one tequila you
can go to taters tequila.com and uh
we'll send it to you
straight to your house and
and give it a try so the uh
i
had this guy the other day sent me a
text that said i don't think you should
use the stage to sell your tequila
that's like why don't you go find a nice
quiet place to [ __ ] yourself
like it was a shade tree online
yeah yeah that's where they all come out
from they all come out from online and
insult you and then
ron white what's it feel like to
50 years from now people are going to
talk about you as one of the [ __ ] top
comics of all time or the top
storytellers i don't think they will
i know they will because they say it now
i don't think that you have a really
loyal following
i bumped into this couple in baltimore
that was was it baltimore it was john
rallo
they were the sweetest couple in the
world and they came to one night and
they go we come to all the shows
and they said recently they had gone to
senior and that was like the fourth
[ __ ] time it said that senior i said
you know people come back and uh and i
love them for it you know i i i try to
move on with the with the stand up to
make it interesting and they're the
reason i keep doing it
you know the
uh
it's
you know the the feeling you get from
just walking on stage and
you know people
you know they just want to bestow
[ __ ] love on you you know with
applause and then you know and and i
keep my chops so i'm still good at what
i do so i'm still going to beat the [ __ ]
out of you don't uh i'm coming i'm
coming there to take a swing at your
face so
and that i will do but it's it's just
amazing because i don't know when you
know when to retire you know they'll let
me know and maybe they you know maybe
they keep listening
you know as long as they keep listening
i'll keep doing it if you thought when i
got into this
when i was 28 years old that i'd be
doing comedy at 54 you're [ __ ] nuts
i thought i was going to do it for 10
years then go to prison
if you're trying to tell me right now
you know how many you know you don't
have an idea ideally
and ron would i feel like when i'm
driving down laurel canyon to go to the
store at nine o'clock at night on a
thursday night
comics come and [ __ ] go you know what
i feel i don't even put the radio on run
i just sit there and absorb it and i
think about how [ __ ] lucky i am
then at 54 i'd go down to the store and
do a spot at 10 45.
it baffles me i thought by now i'd be
dead i'd be just a full-time drug dealer
in and out of [ __ ] uh
jail in new york city i could have never
thought of this
do you think i would ever think of
having a four and a half year old
[ __ ] 54. yeah that's pretty uh that's
pretty rich my friend jesus
christ and guess what when i walk in the
door tonight
she'll be waiting for me my wife will be
[ __ ] out snoring
i'll be in my office ready to go in the
garage that's four and a half years
running loose oh my gosh i hear the door
slam is that my wife
is your come up to me like daddy what
are you doing what the [ __ ] you think
i'm doing i'm about to roll the [ __ ]
number here what are you doing it's 10
after 11 like ron all this [ __ ] to me
i couldn't even imagine so i can't
imagine what you're going through the
last couple years
because i know you were a wreck loose
type of guy like me we just woke up for
the day yeah if we that we gave a [ __ ]
about i love these people what are you
going to be thinking
in 10 years i'm not thinking nothing
i'm thinking about this [ __ ] burrito
i'm going to eat for lunch
i couldn't come up with
they asked me where i was at yeah next
week
because it doesn't matter i'm going to
take you know that's i've got a great
staff and they take care of all that
stuff
you really are taking welcome you do the
right you do it right man
yeah you know the the
the the plane is an extravagance but
it's just like it it's
i'm gonna be dead anyway so why not
spend it you know the uh the plane makes
my life easier and
and uh i don't think any other comic i
mean i know some of them lisa but i
don't know nobody's ever bought one
before
but it made sense to me and uh it looked
like two different jobs one of them paid
a little more and the other one you get
a jet and i was like i'm gonna take the
job with the jet and was that the
coolest thing you've purchased that has
to be the coolest thing to have your own
jet
oh yeah it is
and and even then you know anybody could
argue it's not the smartest thing you
could possibly do but i'm like oh you
you sit on this [ __ ] plane you do 145
cities christ uh within and without
america number one
yeah you can't do it because
logistically you can't get it out of the
city so you literally that plane made me
money because i was willing to do the
sets and i was could sell the tickets
and and uh so i went down and looked at
it one day and i'm like i'll take it so
how many weekends do you got a month
honestly three or four i still do 100 i
did 111 cities last year uh counting
vegas is one city and i did that 11
weekends so i work hard you know i still
go out three usually
i mean i'm really kind of settling off
to two nights a week now because it's
just it's so much easier to do friday
saturday get the [ __ ] out yeah that's
why i'm going back home yeah i think
that's where i'm going to so
it's uh
it's uh but you know
but i'm still doing 12 you know
10 to 12 sets a week in l.a for free so
if you don't want to pay uh me or joey
you don't have to come out to la
and uh
and and go to the comedy store
and uh i mean that's the show last night
they were
i don't even like six or seven comics
make over fifty thousand a night in one
show
for fifteen dollars or whatever galea
rogan
there was that that that's ridiculous
the store yeah wong every night ali
makes that kind of money too
and uh jeselnik i think and uh right
was in the other room
uh
who else you know tony uh in school
uh is a big time you know i don't know
if he's but anyway they were
it it it's it's just an amazing place to
go stand up and say stand up every once
in a while
this is something i also learned from
chris rock don't take anybody with you
when you go down to the club to do a set
don't take your wife don't take your uh
your wife's friends your friends that
aren't comics
don't take anybody don't take your
manager and i think you're gonna take my
little brother here but most of the
lights aren't going to hang out with his
wife
yeah but for the most part
i i have
friends that are exceptions if they're
in town you know or whatever but uh yeah
but if you don't go down there without
them if you don't then you're not a part
of that community because that part of
that community is is is much under
themselves and and uh and you really
aren't yourself
uh
you know when you take somebody with you
that especially a spouse or somebody and
that's something i heard rock say on the
radio i'm like you're right and i was
lucky enough that my girl at the time
heard him say it on the radio and i'm
like you can't argue with that right you
ain't coming no more of these [ __ ]
shows i didn't take my spouse away but i
love my wife
i love that baby
i'm in san francisco next week and we
spoke about it
and i had to throw hot water on it i
throw cold water on i was like i can't
do it
my saturdays i need that salad to write
and be in peace i can't go to the san
francisco zoo
just doesn't work for me
i like to focus i don't even like
selling t-shirts or nothing
i focus on stand-up
and the people who listen to the podcast
i want them to come up to me and shake
my hand i don't need you 20 bucks that
much in the [ __ ] t-shirt you want a
t-shirt go online i just can't do it
i want to focus on the phone you are so
lazy that you won't bring a box of
t-shirts for those adoring fans
[ __ ] them let them go online
my wife will send it to you with a note
i'll send you a cup but i don't wanna
you know why i don't have to put my
[ __ ] glasses on
and start looking through shirts
and making change after the show we're
[ __ ] old dude
i just want to focus on going up there
and if that whatever they pay for the
ticket i want to give them their money's
worth
you know for years i heard these comics
when i was doing nothing as a feature
act i heard comics coming back and going
hey
have you been to tulsa yet oh my god i
sold 1200 in cds
and the comic was god awful
right and even though i was snorting
coke
like a savage
i never sold nothing after the show
even though i was a coke fiend i'd
rather borrow 20 from the bartender
than selling a t-shirt
oh [ __ ] crazy i didn't do it that
much but i i had uh when i i got [ __ ]
into this deal and part of it was i got
a bunch of
cassettes of my show
and uh so i sold it for five bucks a
piece the first night i sold uh 200 of
them and i had this big pile of money
but
now they want money for those to replace
them with and i couldn't i got to sell
for 10 bucks and i'm like
so they kind of died off and
so i don't regulate i don't like to do
extracurricular [ __ ] but you know i do i
do meet and greets that people pay to
come see and and that's a fun thing and
and they enjoy it i love doing meet and
greets
i love talking to people after the show
that listen to the podcast especially
you know as people come up there some
people are just [ __ ] crazy but
there's some people come up and tell you
how much they appreciate
what you do for free and you haven't
scammed them you know with patriarch and
all this [ __ ]
you're just yourself you know and uh
it's it's a great feeling for me i'm
very fortunate
i did time my mother died when i was
young you know
i went out there and put guns to
people's head but here i am in [ __ ]
studios silly la la land baby yeah baby
boy ron white i'm
more than happy that you came on tonight
i uh
use you as an inspiration sometimes i'm
like [ __ ] i'm 54 i should quit then i go
down to the store and there you are with
a two g's [ __ ] suit on with your hair
looking sexy as a [ __ ] with a
drink in your hand and a [ __ ] cigar
letting people know what time it is
following ali wong and i go what the
[ __ ] what kind of [ __ ] is going into
my mind do you understand me
i'm following ron white i'm doing wrong
there's no effort at all what the [ __ ]
nobody beats that room up like he does
don't let him [ __ ] get humble on you
now right before he dies i'm gonna
do some shout outs and read this and
we'll get you the [ __ ] out of here okay
right right home text somebody and see
if they can pick you up and let's get
you home right first off
this podcast is [ __ ] on the seventh
so let's believe the punchline thursday
through saturday
five shows half the shows are sold out
the rest is up to you
and then on the uh 19th
working out with uncle joey at the ice
house 15 bucks
on a saturday night where the [ __ ] you
at ron white you're in new jersey at
montclair no no no no no
morristown
yeah he's in uh and then he's also at uh
what's the name of the theater in
morristown give me one second let me
pull it up well the tickets available
this is my [ __ ] family in jersey
i want you to do me a favor and the way
you supported me at the bogata go see my
[ __ ] savage uncle ron white
what's the name of the theater in
morristown now okay one second sorry
you're what we killed your website your
websites
what's up give me two seconds joey
what's the website anyway ronwhite.com
tatersalad.com
tatersalad.com go there for all [ __ ]
dates all right so friday friday friday
there's two shows at the mayo performing
arts center in morristown new jersey oh
[ __ ] next to the [ __ ] the next day
you wake up and you go to the morristown
funny cars whatever the [ __ ] it is this
is i i used to go there as a kid he's at
the on saturday at the hampton beach
casino ballroom
in hampton beach new hampshire hey can i
tell you a little story about the
hampton beach casino ballroom
it's uh i'm doing a set there and it's
like a it's like a 1700 seat saloon
and uh but it's cool it's fun too i like
doing it
and uh right off the stage there's this
lady she's having a blast and she's
laughing so hard she can't breathe and
and i'm on my tour bus afterwards and
and i see some people waiting out there
for autographs so i come out there and
she comes at me with her mouth opening
her tongue out and she goes do you like
blow jobs
and i was like
not anymore
i did i didn't
right summers i think probably i i was i
was too young i never got to go see a
show there i would we would park right
there and you'd be on the beach that was
that was the first place i took edibles
i'm there every year and a half it's a
blast it's uh
uh it's a you know it's it's it's
something different
that's been around and some days so you
look at it you can't imagine it didn't
burn down [ __ ] 30 years ago
is there a real casino inside i don't
know no there's not i don't know where
they they tacked that on there pretty
loosely because i don't see it because
there's no casino there's no indians in
that [ __ ]
really
really uh aggressive woman that wants to
know
did i do the shout outs yet not yet no
all right crystal jordan my girl
jeremy slay goth jonathan bowers
daniel kyle daniel lowe gareth keenan
ian quindry
allen g you bad [ __ ] scott
carson
austin 930
cassidy and my girl elliot my guy
my main brother from orange county
elliot smith for starters i want to
talk about who puts [ __ ] the church
of what's happening now together
and it's a company called dip recruiter
as our sponsor for tonight are you
hiring do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates no you
don't let me tell you something you know
how hard it is to find good people to
work for you no you don't every day you
get calls from
crazy people they got no resumes they
got no experience but then again they
want all the money in the world with zip
recruiter you can post jobs
to 100 plus job sites with just one
click then their powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job
better than anybody else that's why zip
recruit is different unlike other job
sites
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you guess what it
finds them in fact over 80 percent of
jobs posted
on zip recruiting get qualified
candidates in just 24 hours that's right
no juggling emails no calls to your
office
no shoes in your door simply screen rate
managed candidates all in one place
with zip recruiters easy to use
dashboard find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses or
fall sizes to find the most qualified
job candidates with immediate results in
immediate means
time time means money so right now my
listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for ready for this
free gratis that's right oh gods nothing
just go to zippercooter.com church again
that ziprecruiter.com
church one more time it's going to cost
you nothing go to ziprecruiter.com
church i want to thank roy man ron white
again
yeah
thank you buddy thanks for having me oh
my god this is an honor for us
but i thank you again and uh anytime you
want to come on
you have an open
[ __ ] door your vodka
number one
gila tequila i'm sorry this is how
[ __ ] up how the [ __ ] am i gonna get to
the comedy store dude we'll figure it
out don't worry about none we'll make a
call okay
listen don't forget
next week this thursday friday saturday
the san francisco punch line then the
following saturday i'm at the ice house
working out with uncle joey
trying to come up with new material i
love you [ __ ] stay black
i'll call i'll see you guys next uh
whatever the [ __ ] it is i'm drunk to the
girls guys i don't even know what the
[ __ ] is how are you gonna get look at
what time it is you knew you were doing
this to me no i didn't it's 9 15. you
did you i got you out there you knew i
told you i got to go i got to show you
10 30.
you get me trash 9 15 i got you out of
here you got me trashed dude that's part
of the deal coming out of the church
what's happening now i love you guys
have a great week see you wednesday i
love you with all my heart ron white you
made my [ __ ] month lisa my favorite
jew in the world i love you and tell
these [ __ ] the three wise men
were jewish and they showed up in an
envelope don't show up without an
envelope that's my [ __ ] message
[ __ ] have a great day stay black
hit it lee
[Music]
you